good morning uh bonjour altus biev new
hello uh this press conference regarding
the security situation in ottawa is
being held remotely on saturday february
19th i'm the moderator greg quinn with
market news international
with us today
uh we have marco
marco mendocino minister of public
safety
helena jackson minister responsible for
the federal economic development agency
for southern ontario mary ing minister
of international trade yasser nakhvi
member of parliament for ottawa center
and parliamentary secretary to the
president of the queen's privy council
and minister of emergency preparedness
bill blair minister of emergency
preparedness a uncle avec nuestro dui
lana mona fortier president du
constitute of tresor david lametty
minister de la justice a proclaimer
generator canada a lon arable
for those who have dialed in i remind
everyone to stick to best practices to
minimize outside noise
a proposal question
raise hand
and secondly feel free to identify
yourself and your media outlet when
asking a question and a follow-up
question
i understand we have an hour
uh for opening statements and questions
today
that housekeeping done let's begin with
the opening remarks ministers
merci beaucoup
i'm pleased to be joining you virtually
from the traditional indigenous
territories of the algonquin people and
to be joined by a number of colleagues
who will also be providing updates
within their respective portfolios
yesterday we saw big strides taken
towards restoring public order in ottawa
as a result of a massive joint operation
led by the integrated central command
which is made up of the ottawa police
service the ontario provincial police
and the royal canadian mounted police
so far police have made over 100 arrests
removed many vehicles and have cleared
the areas around rideau and sussex
in fact
many of the blockades in the downtown
core have either left or have been
removed
today
more progress is being made
police are making their way through the
streets
methodically and responsibly
this is encouraging
but the work is not yet done
i want to express my gratitude to all of
the members of the rcmp
the opp
the ottawa police service
and officers from right across the
country who have been working tirelessly
and around the clock to restore order in
ottawa
they have been carrying out their
responsibilities in a
professional proportional
and in a measured manner
yesterday
the ottawa police service interim chief
bell along with members from the rcmp
and opp held a joint press conference
and during that press conference
interim chief bell
noted
the significant action that police have
taken over the last number of days has
been possible thanks to new authorities
granted to the police
under the emergencies act
to quote the chief
without these authorities we wouldn't be
able to do the work we are doing today
this is why our government took the
careful and deliberate decision to
invoke the emergencies act
we've given additional tools to a law
enforcement to ensure that we can
restore public order in ottawa
to keep open our borders for trade and
for economic security
and to ensure that we are upholding
public safety across the country
the very carefully tailored measures
which have been included as part of the
declaration
under the emergencies act
are targeted
they're time limited and they are
charter-guaranteed
this is another example
on how the concrete and targeted
measures under the emergencies act are
being put into effect
we have been able to freeze at least 76
accounts
representing 3.2 million dollars
that were attributable to the illegal
blockades
additionally
fintrac's pre-registration process is
ongoing and it is working with small and
medium-sized banks to implement the
emergency acts orders
as we have said all along
we have taken the decision very
carefully very thoughtfully and as a
measure of last resort to invoke the
emergencies act
it is time limited it is targeted and it
requires compliance with the charter to
ensure that we are protecting the
individual freedoms
and principles and values that are
guaranteed under the charter while at
the same time enabling law enforcement
to do the job on the streets in our
neighborhoods at our borders to uphold
public safety
we will only use the emergencies act for
as long as is necessary
and that is something that we continue
to be focused on every day
thank you very much merci
and i will now pass it back to the
moderator
okay thank you for those statements um
we will now turn to questions uh the
first one i see is
david aiken global news uh david over to
you sorry uh there was maybe other
statements to be said before moderator
if you would let us
yes i'm sorry go ahead thank you
i believe that you're next i believe i
am
good morning everyone bonjour ratus i
would like to acknowledge that i'm
joining you virtually from holland
landing and i am here today on the
traditional territory of the anishinaabe
of the williams treaty first nations
huron wendert and metis nation peoples
for the past three weeks the city of
ottawa has been devastated by illegal
blockades
i've seen firsthand the effects these
illegal blockades have had on ottawa
residents and their businesses
businesses have been forced to
drastically reduce their hours and in
many cases they have had to close their
doors entirely because they have been
harassed and intimidated
throughout the city residents who have
steadfastly supported those businesses
throughout the pandemic no longer feel
safe to go out on the streets of their
city to visit those great local
businesses that help define ottawa's
vibrant neighborhoods
this has taken a tremendous economic and
social toll on the people and
entrepreneurs in ottawa it has
occasioned tremendous inconvenience and
stress and cost millions of dollars in
lost revenue
these businesses play a vital role in
the vitality and economic prosperity of
our nation's capital
ottawa
priest
review
as the prime minister has said many
times these recent challenges have been
unprecedented but our government will be
there as we build towards recovery not
only from this illegal brock paid but
from the pandemic that's why today i'm
proud to announce that the government of
canada through fed dev ontario is
investing up to 20 million dollars to
support ottawa downtown businesses
impacted by the illegal blockades je
suis rose
du canada
[Music]
small businesses in ottawa will be
eligible to receive non-repayable
contributions of up to ten thousand
dollars more details on eligibility and
the applications process will be
available soon this funding will be
delivered by invest ottawa which has a
strong track record of supporting the
business community in ottawa having
delivered targeted programming and
services to businesses for over a decade
invest ottawa is collaborating with key
partners in the region on this
initiative including the ottawa board of
trade and the ottawa coalition of
business improvement areas we are aware
that other areas of ontario have faced
similar struggles and we are looking
into this our government will continue
to work hard to ensure our businesses
communities and all canadians have the
support they need for a strong and
resilient econ economic recovery thank
you merci and i think now i'm turning
over to the honorable mary in
thank you melcy minister jessica it's uh
really great to be here with you and
colleagues as well as to minister
fortier and to parliamentary secretary
nakhvi and to all of the ottawa area
members of parliaments who have been
incredible advocates for their
constituents throughout this challenging
time
as workers small businesses and people
across the country have struggled
through this pandemic these past three
weeks have even been more difficult for
businesses at the heart of our nation's
capital whether it's elgin bank sparks
or the market i've heard from
entrepreneurs and small businesses
across ottawa and just when those very
businesses across our province have been
opening their doors again
businesses here have had to close theirs
for the safety of their staff and that
of their customers
and that has been unacceptable
this 20 million dollars in support from
our government will bring much needed
relief to heavily impacted ottawa
businesses and i want to thank invest in
ottawa for their ongoing collaboration
with feddev to deliver this important
support
today's announcement is just one more
step that our government is taking to
support small businesses since the start
of this pandemic we've invested in
crucial supports including the wage
subsidy the wrench subsidy the hardest
hit business recovery program and
recently extended lockdown supports
businesses have relied on these programs
and will continue to have to count on
them so that we can bridge them to
recovery as the prime minister deputy
prime minister
and my ministerial colleagues have said
no one has the right to illegally occupy
our cities disturb our communities and
to cause serious harm by shutting down
small businesses and preventing
hard-working canadians from being able
to work
we will continue to have your backs
through
this pandemic just as we have done
and we will drive towards a strong
inclusive and sustainable economic
recovery and to the canadians who are
listening to this
when these businesses reopen please
support our local businesses in ottawa i
know i will thank you so very much merci
to lemon and over to you minister
fortier
thank you mary bonjour merci for that
good morning and thank you all for
joining us today
we know that in the past weeks many
businesses have been forced to close
their doors and have been subjected to
intimidation
harassment
violence and hatred
this situation has caused major
disruptions of access it has impacted
staffing delivery of goods
and generated significant loss of
revenue
this is unacceptable
we are here to let you know we stand
with you and we will continue to have
your back
today's announcement demonstrates our
government's commitment to making sure
our downtown ottawa businesses have the
relief funds they need to recover
in the past weeks i've had numerous
conversations with mayor watson i've
also spoken and listened at lengths with
city councillors
representatives of local dias okobia the
ottawa business trade le regenda capital
ottawa and business and community
leaders
i have been actively engaged with
concerned businesses owners
residents and organizations through
countless phone calls emails and text
messages
they have shared first hand with me the
disruptions to their livelihood and
well-being
is
foreign
thank you very much
for the past 22 days members of my
community have been held hostage by an
unlawful occupation
le
they have been harassed subjected to
hurtful and racist symbols and there has
been reports of assaults
for weeks many businesses downtown have
had to close their doors to ensure staff
safety and security of their shops
whether that is moo shu ice cream on
bank street ayana restaurant on o'connor
or yemen dim sum on kent street they and
others have all had an incredibly rough
time
the list goes on and on
throughout the pandemic the federal
government has been there for small
businesses and workers
now is no different
i'm pleased that today's funding
announcement will help businesses in
ottawa's downtown core
recover from the impacts of these
protests so that they can continue
serving our community
thank you to invest ottawa for helping
us quickly distribute the support to
those in need
we know how valuable invest ottawa has
been for our region and for so many
businesses who have been impacted by the
pandemic and will now be there to
support businesses who have been
impacted by these unlawful protests
i would also like to address the workers
who have been impacted by these protests
please do know that we are seeking
further measures that can provide relief
for you
at this time the canada worker lockdown
benefit cwlb which gives temporary
income support to employed and
self-employed people who cannot work due
to covet 19 lockdown continues to be
available my colleagues and i are
working closely together to seek further
measures that will provide support
during this difficult time
and finally to the residents of centre
town
i know this has been an unimaginably
difficult time
no we will get through this together
and better days are to come
thank you everyone for joining merci
atus
media availability will now follow thank
you
thank you ministers messi um
again if you have a question uh on the
call please use the race hand button to
indicate your interest uh i will turn to
the first question
uh david aiken global news
uh thank you very much greg and thank
you ministers um i don't have a
statement just questions
um and the first one uh i guess uh
probably from minister medicine or mr
lemetti but um
i guess
minister from the china i think you
mentioned that this emergency exactly
remain in place
as as long as it needs to and i'm
watching what seems to be a very
successful police operation
we hope wrap up right now here in ottawa
what are you looking for as the public
safety minister
to say right that's it we don't need the
special powers anymore in place what
what are some of the things that
canadians can say ah i see
that the this can be lifted and to be
honest could it be lifted by the end of
the weekend
well i think it's an important question
and as i've said a number of times david
that the situation is very fluid so i
agree with you on the surface there does
appear to be good progress that is being
made on the streets in ottawa and i do
want to take a moment to
express our profound gratitude to
the members of law enforcement who've
been carrying out this work under
extraordinarily difficult conditions um
it's not just the
um it's not just all of the uncertainty
uh that the illegal blockades and those
who are dug in uh present but yesterday
uh the weather took a turn for the worse
and and certainly um you know we're
we're watching all of the
all of those variables uh play out uh in
real time and um
we're all on pins and needles uh for
the safety of um those who are on the
streets um the principally the the
residents who as you heard from mp
nakvia and minister fortier uh have been
under siege uh now for for far too long
uh we're concerned for the safety
of uh those law enforcement individuals
who are carrying out their
responsibilities with great
professionalism and under incredible
stress
and we're also concerned for
the safety of of those individuals who
have become
intermingled with the illegal blockades
thus far
i think we're all relieved that there
has been a very minimum amount of
confrontation and violence and we
certainly hope that that will continue
to be the case going forward in the best
way for that to happen is that those who
are still here go home as uh we have
said time and time again and as for the
emergencies act there are many
safeguards that are built into the act
to uh to assure that we only use it for
as long as is necessary and and so when
it comes to making that determination as
to when the conditions are no longer
present such that the emergencies act
are required the declaration and the
orders are required
first and foremost
i want to make sure that we take the
advice of law enforcement
we're in routine
touch with
the commissioner of the rcmp and with
other members of law enforcement um
we'll
let them assess
operationally
since it is their domain of expertise
whether or not they think the situation
is in hand so yes
there has been progress but the
situation remains dynamic it remains
fluid and we'll wait to see how things
unfold in the coming hours and days
uh thanks and a follow-up probably for
you as well mr manufino um we know that
there were some arrested in coutes who
were associated with some
extremist far-right groups just diagonal
on some groups that uh
that are known presumably to authorities
national security authorities etc um
that they may advocate violence we also
know i think you've said this early in
the week that there may be some elements
in the protest here in ottawa
associated with those groups so i'm
wondering with the 100 or so arrested
now
do you have anything more you can tell
us about the presence in
ottawa of any elements
um any individuals who might be
associated with some of these groups
that
did represent some violent threats is
there anything you can share on that
front
well just what you see in the public
domain and on social media and those uh
reports are are very uh public around
the movements of some individuals from
uh one blockade to the other but as to
the charges
which uh stem from the illegal blockade
in kutz which include among other things
the conspiracy to commit murder those
are now before the courts david it would
be inappropriate for any member of the
government to comment further on it um
obviously as those charges play out uh
in court and uh will be assigned to a
prosecutor uh there will be more uh
details shared about exactly what
particulars um you know underlie the
situation there but but i will say that
as a government we are looking at the
big picture we are looking at the timing
the tactics the targets of the illegal
blockades and i just want to assure you
and everyone that both the law
enforcement and our national security
apparatus are watching the situation
very very carefully
thank you merci uh president questions
is
uh
donation
thank you next question
christian paslang
cbc
hi thanks um
mr medicina this is probably for you you
mentioned the amount of accounts that
have been frozen and the number of uh
and the amount of money involved in that
uh can you clarify for us what happens
to the money in the accounts when
they're frozen and what may happen uh
following
the end of the emergency
well the operationalization of the
measures under the emergencies act is
something that is being undertaken by
police in conjunction with financial
institutional partners including the
banks um so that is being done on on on
the in an independent manner on the
operational side and it would be uh
inappropriate for us to comment further
due to operational sensitivity and to
preserve the integrity of what is going
on right now which is a very
sophisticated
highly coordinated
operation that is being carried out by
enforcement in real time but i would
stress
that the numbers that we have
been able to provide to you thus far
again with uh the
cooperation and the advice of law
enforcement
shows very obviously how the emergencies
act is being used to bring about
the conclusion and the peaceful
conclusion of the illegal blockades
this is
one of the measures uh which
uh does not require to be
operationalized on the streets uh
where there's whereas there's the
prospect of confrontation or physical
violence but rather by using a powerful
financial disincentives
to encourage
those to uh to leave and to leave as
quickly as possible and to not support
the illegal blockades
i'd also point out that yesterday
interim chief bell who is
the current uh police chief of the
ottawa police service
stressed that they would not be able to
be carrying out the operations that are
playing out right now in the streets of
ottawa but for the invocation of the
emergencies act now this is a
non-partisan
professional police officer with many
years of experience on the front lines
who understands what existing
authorities there were prior to the
emergencies act being introduced who has
said in no uncertain terms that this is
an important and an essential tool
and while we're seeing progress um
it is important to recognize that the
operation is not yet concluded and so i
think here we have an example
of someone with great experience and
perspective uh understanding and
recognizing that
up until the introduction of the
emergencies act that there were many
challenges that had been presented to
police into law enforcement uh in in
bringing about the end of the illegal
blockades and not only here in ottawa uh
but right across the country and i want
to assure you
and everyone that is watching that this
is a tool that is being used effectively
to bring about the conclusion of the
illegal blockades peacefully
expeditiously but within the parameters
of the charter
for my follow-up
while the police operation is happening
in downtown ottawa mp mps just really
meters away are debating the emergencies
act in the house of commons can can
maybe mr mendocino again can you
describe any steps that might have been
taken
um to
you know secure
uh the house of commons
while this is all going on
security on the hill is uh governed by
the sergeant-at-arms and
the pps who has the jurisdictional
responsibility to ensure security on the
hill but i
i want to emphasize that there have been
open lines of communication between the
pps the sergeant-at-arms as well as the
rcmp and members of the integrated
central command
um we're very concerned uh for the
safety of mps and staff and all
parliamentarians who are working on the
hill in fact as you saw
um you know many of the blockades were
concentrated on wellington street at
rideau and sussex and you know it is
quite impressive that thus far the
enforcement operation
has been carried out uh without uh there
being any uh significant casualties or
violence thus far i think that that is a
real tribute to uh the police services
and the first responders who have shown
up who despite the challenging
circumstances are are are doing a very
effective job uh showing restraint and
patience uh and showing i think a very
level-headed approach
and for though and what that has done is
it has enabled us to allow parliament to
sit because it is important that
parliamentarians have an opportunity to
debate the emergencies act this is the
first time it has been invoked
we do need to be transparent with
canadians uh from the government's point
of view
the measures that we have introduced are
very targeted they're very circumscribed
to the circumstances
that present us and they have to be
consistent with the charter and we're
very motivated to to giving
all parliamentarians an opportunity to
debate very publicly in the open chamber
those measures so that we can be
informed as to the necessity of the
emergencies act so we can bring about
the end uh the peaceful conclusion to
the illegal blockades
thank you uh i'll make
one last call around to see if anyone
uh has wants to raise their hand for a
question and in the meantime i'll i'll
throw one in i wanted to know about the
the economic risk behind the emergency
we've seen border blockades
um
how how might the government respond
if we see another uh border being border
crossing being blocked after the
emergency order lifts would would
economic damage to canada be enough to
to bring in emergency measures or to
take other strong action
it's an important question i'll say a
few words and then i'll pass to uh
minister lametty and other colleagues
but but certainly the economic impact
that was caused by the blockades at the
ambassador bridge to the tune of nearly
400 million dollars a day uh that idled
jobs that saw plants shut down that
created a devastating negative impact on
the manufacturing sector but not only in
southwestern ontario uh across various
supply chains cannot be overstated and
and certainly given the tactics that
have been used by the illegal blockades
to
interrupt those supply chains at our
borders at other critical infrastructure
including at national symbols like
parliament like provincial legislatures
like some of our war monuments remains a
going concern uh and so
there there is absolutely an economic
aspect to this that does present a very
uh serious threat to our economic
security to our trade relations with the
united states and other partners which
are critically important to our
sovereignty and that is indeed one of
the things that i think minister
lametty's
rationale and explanation paper in
support of the invocation of the
emergencies act spells out and i will
turn it uh to him to elaborate further
uh thanks marco what i would underline
is that in the invocation of this of
this
emergency so the use of the emergencies
act in this circumstance it was the
ensemble of of of the various uh
challenges at a number of different
border crossings as well as the
situation in ottawa as well as ongoing
uh as well as ongoing uh
surveillance if you will of other border
crossings as this went as this went
along and so it was all of that together
with the economic impact that it was
causing
uh should we should we take away uh the
emergencies act
and a situation were to arise again we
would we would have to evaluate so it's
a hypothetical question to which none of
us will ever give you an answer it's
something that we have to we have to
think about in each circumstance uh
minister blair wonder if you have
anything to add
uh only only david thank you david and
only that the the you know the targeted
uncoordinated attacks we saw on on
critical trade corridors um at the
ambassador bridge in alberta and at in
emerson manitoba the pacific highway in
british columbia you know clearly um
demonstrated a very sincere intent on
the on the part of the people engaged in
those illegal blockades to harm the
country we saw the impact in in
southwestern ontario and in the auto
sector and literally thousands of
workers who were idled by the actions of
these individuals you know the the cost
and the potential future cost to canada
by these illegal actions is very very
significant and and when we see targeted
attacks on critical infrastructure such
as transportation and manufacturing in
this country
i think we have a responsibility to
defend the country to defend canadian
interests and defend our economy and and
we have found it necessary obviously to
use um extraordinary measures and tools
in these circumstances in order to do
our job of doing what is required to
protect the country and we'll always
stand on guard for for canada's interest
and and and support uh the important
work that law enforcement does and
others um in keeping canada safe
can i just make a comment here around
international trade it is extremely
important that uh that our trading
partners continue to have the confidence
in
uh in our relationship and particularly
in this trading relationship i won't
repeat what colleagues have already said
but in canada one out of six jobs in our
country is related to trade so it's very
very important to the economic security
and that of the jobs and people in our
communities across the country
thank you uh
i see no more questions on the line
so unless you'd like to give any final
comments it appears to be all we have
for today so thank you merci
migrant thank you
you